yo soy paulina
y les vengo a contar una historia
quiero que por favor cierren cada uno de
sus ojos y visualicen lo que es la
compasión
ya sea en una imagen en un escrito con
colores con arco iris como sea ahora los
abrimos
y des cruzamos nuestros brazos
les voy a contar la historia de alma
alma es la más pequeña de 13 hermanos
una familia disfuncional donde la
violencia la delincuencia era el modus
vivendi de la familia
la cuna de alma estaba en una esquina en
una cajita si bien le iba alguna vecina
o su hermano oa veces y tenía la suerte
su mamá pasaba a cambiar el pañal pero
así fue su vida nadie le enseñó a comer
nadie le enseñó a que era tener amor
nadie nadie le enseñó nada ahí se quedó
en casa de alma se cocinaba una vez al
día
era una mesa imagínense ustedes de 15
personas y alma el pilón
la consentida era la que estaba hasta el
final de la mesa si había apoyo entonces
el papá empezaba a comer y alma le
tocaba lo último los huesitos los cuales
se los devoraba los mordía porque sólo
sabía que a las 24 horas a lo mejor iba
a comer ésta era la luz su única
esperanza
a los siete años alma fue abusada
sexualmente por un familiar
de ahí otro familiar de ahí los vecinos
de ahí los amigos y ahí nació la mina de
oro de la familia de alma que en
negocios tener alma en su casa
ejerciendo la prostitución brava
imágenes de ustedes la infancia de alma
ahora quiero que se vuelvan a cerrar sus
ojos
y visuales en la empatía
así también en una palabra una imagen
con colores ahora abrimos des cruzamos
los brazos y nos preparamos a oír sin
prejuicios otra historia
yo no sé ustedes pero por ejemplo en mi
generación nos educaban mucho para que
nos íbamos a casar con el príncipe azul
el vestido él nos iba a recoger de todos
los males que teníamos y vamos a tener
hijos y vamos a tener una casa el anillo
la fiesta todo era precioso
a mí por lo menos eso me pasó
qué tal que yo les dijera que esta
persona una niña preciosa iba caminando
por la calle en tal estado de
descomposición y tal hartazgo que se
encontró con un señor y le dijo oye nena
bonita porque era muy bonita de casas
conmigo y te doy este pedazo de pan si
como no
ese fue su príncipe azul
ese príncipe azul la violentó le pegó en
la introducción al narcomenudeo al
narcotráfico obviamente tenía que estar
drogada para hacer tanta cosa que no
quería dejó de sentir
porque lo que sentía
evitaba que le dieran de comer al día
siguiente
cuando se quedó embarazada
tuvo tal golpiza de su marido
que aterrizó en un hospital
con los brazos rotos con la pierna rota
obviamente perdió a su bebé la cara
destrozada sin dientes
y perdió la oportunidad de ser madre
otra vez
la historia no
qué tal que yo les dijera que esta es la
misma historia la misma persona la misma
alma
qué duro no
ella viviendo esa violencia extrema y
cuando encuentra su príncipe azul otra
vio lanza atrás a los 37 años alma entro
en el reclusorio femenil de tepepan
donde trabajamos un equipo de 5
colaboradoras
entro en silla de ruedas sin poder
hablar enojada
vomitando odio rencor pues como no la
habían agarrado y pensaba que le iba a
peor que en la calle
en el reclusorio femenil de tepepan hay
300 internas de las cuales nada más el
90% reside en visita de sus familiares
alma no iba a recibir visitas de nadie
cómo actuar como
llegar a su alma valga la redundancia
como poder tocar ese corazón tan herido
alma empezó a abrir se empezó a escuchar
empezó a platicar empezó a recibir
terapias empezó a hacer ejercicios para
su pierna
y se empezó a rehabilitar
porque nos encontramos alma y nosotros y
nuestra fundación porque nos tocamos por
esta empatía porque al escuchar el
acompañar el gear es el servicio y el
servicio es lo que nosotros tenemos que
pasar a las nuevas generaciones y a los
que están cerca de nosotros el servicio
la ayuda es fabulosa la ayuda es que me
den
y cosas para llevar a la cárcel que me
ayuden a subir una escalera que me
ayuden a subir un coche pero el servicio
viene desde acá
viene desde acompañar desde tocar hay
una analogía que yo siempre platico que
es
entonces muy chistosa venía caminando yo
en la cárcel
y una de las internas llegó para me
gustan muchísimo tus tenis me lo regalas
yo pues sí eran unos trenes ergonómicos
súper cómodos para correr
ok yo te doy los míos los de ella eran
unas zapatillas de brillantina plateada
con un atr hábitat y eran de un disfraz
era verídico
pero le dije la única condición es que
los quiero ver bien puestos y que los
traigas cada vez que vengas conmigo y ya
no te drogues
ok me puse los zapatos y los 200 metros
que también de ese lugar a mi coche me
salen unas ampollas que dice yo cómo
puede caminar esta mujer en este zapato
le van a venir muy bien los míos
pasarán dos o tres semanas
y no la vi y como la cuarta semana llegó
me dijo pau qué crees ya no me drogo
aquí están tus tenis
yo no los tenis son tuyos no no no no no
tus tenis me sacaron muchísimas ampollas
yo como tú si mis tenis eran los más
cómodos del mundo o sea cómo te iban a
sacar ampollas me puse en tus zapatos y
yo creo que tú te pusiste en los míos y
es ahí cuando entendí lo que era la
empatía el caminar con los zapatos del
otro
creo que tu vida se enmarca por el
número de vidas que tocas ya sea 12 22
36 40 y 2000
pero si no acompaña si no escuchas y si
no te entregas no está sirviendo estás
ayudando
mi marido
tenía una frase
que decía no puedes
predecir el futuro pero si lo puedes
construir
y yo creo que esta parte del
acompañamiento y la empatía y la
compresión son lo que debemos construir
para nuestros hijos para los que vengan
es como cuando tiras una piedra a una
alberca primero se revuelve y luego se
hacen ondas expansivas y un círculo
virtuoso armonioso y te toca muchísimas
vidas
tú cambias cuando tocas una vida
y creo que el acompañar es eso la
empatía y la comprensión
alma
murió
a los 42 años víctima de una enfermedad
de transmisión sexual
y con un lío de páncreas claro por la
vida que había llevado
pero les puedo asegurar en mi persona y
a nombre de la organización que
represento que alma murió feliz
se revalorizó dentro de un lugar tan
oscuro como un penal revalorizó su alma
revalorizó todos los sentidos en que
encontró el amor encontró la empatía se
reía encontró amigas y cerró y se murió
rodeada de amor eso es la clave del
servir que toque es un alma
yo quiero por medio
de esta maravillosa plataforma
invitarles a que toquen un alma
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]